you
[Music]
it's a pleasure to introduce Faraz Abu
Zeid who's going to be giving us a
presentation that he's gonna give at
vldb a couple weeks he'd like to present
this under conference conditions so he
wants to lecture straight through with
no interruptions for questions and then
we can do as much Q&A afterwards as your
heart desires so so it's only 15 minutes
it's only 15 you can ask as many
questions I advised him to not rush it
so that just to see what the timing is
like under under a normal normal speech
speed we'll see how it goes anyway let
me turn it over to for us thanks Phil hi
everyone thanks for coming today
so as Phil mentioned my name is Feroz
I'm a fifth year PhD student at Stanford
working with Peter Bayliss and Matteo
haria today I'm we were talking about a
project called DIF which is a relational
interface that we proposed for large
scale with data explanation before I
jump in I wanted to thank all of the
collaborators that we worked with on
this project not only the folks I work
with at Stanford but also folks from
Microsoft from Facebook and at Google
without them this project definitely
would've been possible
so the high-level focus of our work is
trying to explain trends and high volume
data which is a fundamental challenge
for a lot of data analysts today so to
illustrate why this is so challenging
let's think of an example let's say that
you're trying to track a mobile apps
user engagement and you're some product
manager and you're trying to figure out
why the number of daily active users for
your app is declined in the last week
okay now if you're this p.m. you pretty
much have to do the following you have
to go through and inspect thousands of
possible causes in your data you're
looking at the metrics of different
users across your app and there's all
sorts of possible factors right there's
user demographic data
there's device and location metadata
there's probably to implore with some
seasonal factors depending on what the
app is and there's probably usually some
combinations of factors that are at play
here right
possibly time portal and user
demographic data is shaping something in
the data right this becomes a really
tedious and arduous task for the product
manager right
if you're using your standard OLAP or bi
tools what you basically have to end up
doing is you manually search through all
these possible combos right you write a
series of group I or cube queries you're
slicing your diet you're slicing and
dicing your data repeatedly until you
hit that magic sweet spot or you find
that needle in the haystack right so
people have proposed what are called
explanation Enders that's the term that
I'm gonna use in this talk they've
proposed explanation engines that try to
automate this search process right and
this is an active area of research for
the last five years or so in the
database community so for example out of
our group at Stanford we proposed the
macro based system at Sigma 2017 but
there's also been scorpion at vldb 2013
there's been data x-ray at Sigma 2015
and some work from u-dub from Ryan su
chio at Sigma 2014 right and more or
less with these explanation engines aim
to do is they're trying to identify
particular features that artistically
significant and moving some particular
metric that you as an analyst karabell
so for example if you're trying to track
the the da u of that particular app your
exploration engine might identify that
okay it's device make apple and this
particular OS version and this
particular app version that's giving you
a 2x you know
decrease in the DI you write what these
exploration engines typically offer is
pretty powerful but they're sort of
lacking two core missing pieces right
the first is interoperability right if
you're a data analyst have an
explanation is really handy but chances
are it's going to exist as some part of
larger workflow right you're doing some
ETL and then you're doing nutritional
OLAP query you might be doing the
visualization and then you also want to
find the explanation right it's very
rare that you are doing this sort of
explanation finding in a silo but the
problem is that these exploration
engines are usually standalone tools and
so the interoperability piece is
actually pretty hard to navigate the
second issue is scalability right most
these analysts these days are trying to
figure out these explanations in an
interactive setting right because you're
usually using this to do some sort of
monitoring for example and if your data
set is changing at a very high ball I'm
a very fast pace you don't have the time
to analyze this overnight you need to
know within seconds or within minutes
and so if you can't scale that that
volume of data then your exhibition
engine for all of its power is intact
the useful so in today's talk I want to
talk about our proposal that sort of
tackles both of these problems
simultaneously and that's the differ so
the differ is a declarative relational
operator right and we decided to make
this a declarative relational operator
so that we can unify the core
functionality of these different
explanation engines and also address
interoperability challenges that I
talked about on the previous slide right
so if you have a relational operator now
can integrate with all of your standard
OLAP queries all of your typical BI
tools it can it can integrate with ETL
with pretty much any type of data
cleaning or data analysis pipeline that
you already have existing right you can
also take existing engines like macro
base or data x-ray or quick insights or
scorpion and integrate or rewrite those
queries using our same interface right
that's kind of the ideal situation right
one unit one interface to rule them all
essentially and the nice thing is that
once you propose this relational
operator you can actually start to play
the same sort of game that we in the
Database community love to do we have a
relational interface now we're going to
apply query optimization on it right and
so in this work we actually proposed new
logical and physical optimizations for
this operator that actually make it
scalable and to show that this actually
works we have a scalable implementation
of DIF that we've open-sourced online we
integrated DIF as an extension to the
original macro based code base so we
call it macro be sequel and we also have
actually a single node and distributed
implementation in SPARC so that we can
really test the scalability of this okay
so to show you how this works I want to
walk you guys through an example
workflow using diff right let's say
we're gonna use a slightly different
example we're not gonna look at daily
active users we're gonna look at crash
logs right so here's my sample table of
crash logs I've got three columns that
sort of encode different categorical
features and I've also got a time step
and I've got the actual crash or there's
true or false right so pay attention to
the app version device type in OS
columns okay
so let's analyze his crash logs using
diff what I want to do is I want to
figure out why is my app crashing what's
what's driving the increase in crashes
over the last couple of weeks or
literally the last week so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna select row star
and I'm gonna take out the subset of
tuples that have crashes and I'm going
to dip that with the remaining tuples
where the crashes didn't
right so I'm going to use my differ
operator to compare crash logs versus
success logs okay and what I'm going to
do is I'm going to basically use diff
what diff tries to do is it does a group
by effectively on the different possible
combinations of dimensions that I care
about so here I'm going to look at app
version device type in OS so it's going
to do a group by account group by on all
single columns so just app version just
device type just OS all pairs and all
triples in this case we're skin limited
triples for the sake of this
presentation and then what I'm going to
do is I'm going to compare the counts
and the two different tables so I'm
doing a group I on the crash logs I'm
gonna grip on the success logs right and
I've got my counts per attribute value
combinations in these two different
tables and then once I've got my two
different counts for all the different
groups I'm going to compare them based
on these two different metrics right
risk ratio and support and you can think
of risk ratio and support is basically
measuring the prevalence of these two
different of the of the different groups
in two different ways basically it's
kind of telling me you know what I only
care about things that are 2x more
likely for example in the crash logs but
at least show up five percent of the
time that's kind of the the intuitive
notion of risk ratio and support okay so
what I'll get back is it'll get back
this table right so diff takes in two
relations it outputs a single relation
just like a joint would okay and what
I've got now is I've got the three
columns that I cared about app version
device type in OS and I've got my two
metrics which I'll define in a second
risk ratio and support and basically
this now is an explanation that's
telling me hey the combination of this
particular app version this particular
device type in this particular OS is
nine point seven five times more likely
to cause crashes and it shows up 20
percent of the time in the crash logs
right I've got other explanations to
write these values here that are dashes
are just pretty much nulls right so it's
saying that this combination is what's
causing the problem as are these two as
well okay now let's say okay I've run
this query I found these results and you
know what I think that third row is
really really interesting because the
first one I get it a Persian one was
really old it's gonna cause lots of
crashes and I know that the iPhone X
rollout was really really buggy so I'm
just gonna ignore that for now but this
particular combination is
pretty alarming because a lot of my
users are using galaxy s 9 so I want to
make sure this is the problem right I'm
gonna use my same interface now but I'm
gonna do a time series comparison I'm
gonna compare week to week so I'm gonna
do again select from star now all I've
done is I've swapped out the two
relations I'm using the same operator
but now I'm comparing this week to last
week okay I'm going to use the exact
same columns to come to compare against
and I'm gonna use the same metrics to
compare on and now I get back a single
tupple it's the same combination but now
it says okay between this week and last
week the risk ratio increased to 20
right so now it's 20 times more likely
right and it showed up 75% of the time
so what's really moving things in the
last week is this particular combination
in a sense it confirmed my original
hypothesis from that first query right
so hopefully these two queries kind of
encapsulates for you the power of why
this interface is so relevant right
because so long as it takes in any two
relations you can compare anything you
want right now what we found is actually
this operator has a lot of applications
in successful use cases in both industry
and in academia so here's just a small
collection of folks that we've worked
with that have Illustrated why it's so
powerful at Google or Microsoft at
Facebook we've seen people use it for
monitoring different systems analyzing
crashes trying to track user engagement
the census project actually is another
interesting example of this census was a
security research project that's now a
start-up where essentially people have
collected Internet port scan data all
over the world over years and years and
years and what we've done in the census
project with DIF is we've been able to
do time series analysis and try to
explain hey for example you know these
ports were all open and month ago but
now they're all closed something is
fishy right or these devices were online
in India but now they're offline that
might be something you should check out
right essentially what the reason why we
were motivated by this is that one of
the professors at Stanford who started
the census project was responsible for
tracking a famous botnet that came up a
few years ago called the Mirai botnet
and so he basically challenged us to use
DIF to sort of find the moriah botnet
from scratch which took you know his
research team months and months and
months to find so that's why we decided
to work with them just to be very
precise I want to make sure I go through
all of the elements of the operator so
you guys understand exactly what it
entails
so here's that first query that I showed
you a few slides ago the two things that
you should worry about and care in terms
of the relations are the test relation
in the control relation so we're doing
here is we have some test relation that
we care about I care about finding
anomalies are explaining anomalies in
that test and I'm gonna compare it
against some control okay and then I'm
gonna have a set of dimensions that I
care about and for our tents and
purposes the dimensions are always going
to be categorical features you could use
continues features but you have to have
some way of binning them and
discretizing them basically and then you
have your difference metrics which are
telling you okay once you do the
comparisons on these particular columns
or all these particular dimensions I
want to use these particular metrics to
track the movers to try and sort of
populate the folks who are or causing
these particular trends to surface right
and each difference what trick is
associated with a threshold so in this
case the risk ratio difference metric
has a threshold of 2.0 and the support
metric has a threshold of 0.05 there's
one final optional parameter that we
have in the diff query which is sort of
the max order of combinations so what
you can say here is you can say oh I
want to explore only order two
combinations or order four combinations
for example but again for this talk
we'll just focus on order three because
that tends to be sufficient for most use
cases okay I want to focus your
attention on the difference metrics
because that's actually I think where
the power of the abstraction really lies
because what's nice about the difference
metric is that once you've defined this
interface you can use this to generalize
to other explanation engines so for
example in macro base we used risk ratio
and support and that's the example that
I've shown you so far but if I wanted to
encapsulate did x-ray all I have to do
is rewrite the diagnosis cost but they
did actually folks came up with as a
difference metric and now I've got the
exact same result and we actually have
extramental results that show how this
works if wanting to you know capture the
semantics of scorpion I just redefined
the influence metric that they've
defined in their paper and I've also now
captured their course semantics as well
if I want to you know take take the work
of ROI and suture from Sigma 2014 I just
defined the intervention difference
metric and if I want to do just basic
frequent itemsets mining I just use
support yeah okay so now let me sort of
talk about some of the logical
optimizations hopefully now I've
convinced you that diff is something you
know worth using so
say I've got this particular query let's
say now what I want to do is I want to
run my diff query but before I actually
take the different we two different
relations I want to do a natural join
with some additional table right so for
example I want to augment my crash logs
with some user metadata let's say to
give me a broader search bunch of things
that I can search over right so what
this would look like as a standard query
plan right is I've got the diff at the
top I've got two joins and then I've got
my four tables at the bottom right so
the idea that we came up with was what
if we take the different and we push it
below the joint right which doesn't seem
to make a lot of sense at first but I
think the key that you should think
about is instead of doing it on the
entire table we're only going to do is
we're only going to push it on the
foreign key column so what we
effectively do here is we have this
adaptive algorithm where first we take
the diff and we evaluate it on just the
foreign key column of crash logs and
success logs and we find essentially a
set of candidate keys now if that output
is really really large we'll just abort
and we'll use the standard approach
we'll use this the approach of just
taking the joins and then doing the diff
after that but if that can't if that
pool of candidate keys is really small
that effectively prunes our search space
quite a bit right and so now what we can
do is we can take that set of candidate
keys we send me join them with that
users table and now we have a set of
candidate values right and so once we
have the set of candidate values now we
can just evaluate the different second
time on those candidate values and that
gives us our result right and so later
on I'll show you some experience where
we actually use this to accelerate one
particular query on a pretty large data
set from Microsoft and we also have the
synthetic example where we actually I
find sort of the ideal sweet spot where
you should trade off between the naive
approach in this adaptive approach
there's one more additional optimization
that I don't have time to talk about
right now but you can also actually use
functional dependencies in the data to
prune the search space as well so you
don't have to examine all possible
combinations okay now for the physical
optimizations that we came up with a lot
of these are actually pretty standard
that you would see in a traditional OLAP
engine so for example we dictionary
encode you know these low support values
that aren't coming up very frequently we
encode them using bitmaps I think one
thing that's a bit different
most folks when they see this is that we
use a cost model to identify when to use
bitmaps and when not to so it's sort of
a cardinality aware case it turns out
that if the cardinality is really high
you shouldn't encode things with bitmaps
because then you just have a memory
blow-up and it just becomes really
really expensive
we also encode things in a linear and a
columnar format so that we can you know
maximize cache locality and then we use
an embarrassingly parallel plantation of
a priori so we can explore the future
combinations in parallel this goes
against actually most of the literature
and data mining most folks were actually
recommend that use FP growth because
it's supposed to be much faster in the
single node case but it peoria is much
easier to paralyze so we ended up using
that as an implementation okay so
actually not talking about
implementation we have two different
permutations of macro base so the first
and the single node was a fork of the
original macro base repo we essentially
wrote our own sequel parser to support a
subset of sequel and of course diff and
then we also have a spark implementation
where we actually integrated with the
spark data from API we can implement our
optimizations with the catalyst
optimizer in spark because it's a
rule-based optimization and then
essentially the diff queries are
optimized using these catalyst rules and
then they're transit it to some
equivalent spark job using the
composition of maps and filters and
group bys there's also a kind of a cute
pruning optimization that we talked
about in the paper that reduces the
communication costs and it's about 1.5
1.6 lines of Java code yeah and it's
also open source as well so I encourage
you guys to check out the documentation
online and read more about it if you're
interested ok in the last few minutes I
have I'm gonna walk you guys through
some evaluation results that we have so
here are the 5 data sets that we used we
took two data sets from the Census folks
we also were lucky enough to work with
the Microsoft teams here in Bellevue and
obtain two production data sets from
them which is very very generous of them
and then we also found a public data set
from the center of Medicare that just
basically gave us a lot of data to play
with and give it sort of another use
case to to measure the efficacy of DIF
so we benchmarked on a single machine
using 500 gigs of RAM and we benchmarked
Maccabee sequel against these five
different engines
and then for each dataset we would
execute a DIF Cory and measure the
end-to-end runtime and the ingest time
was omitted and whenever possible we
would try our we try our best to sort of
mimic a query that was being run in
production when we benchmark this stuff
so we would anonymize the tables for
example and then run things as if it was
in production and then for all of the
queries that we ran unless otherwise
noted in the paper we used the risk
ratio of we risk ratio and support of
difference metrics and we use a max
order of three and we also use
categorical features for our dimensions
so I'll just give a few highlights the
first one is that when we benchmarked
against the oldest version of macro base
in Postgres macro race equal tended to
be much much faster so on the left hand
side is just the end-to-end runtime in
log scale on that and the x-axis are the
five different data sets and this is for
risk ratio and support the two things
that I kind of want to highlight are
again this is a log scale so you know
you know macro base equal is able to
outperform by multiple orders of
magnitude against macro basins in
Postgres this asterisk here is actually
indicating that Postgres wasn't able to
explore all order 3 combinations it
turns out that Postgres limits how many
group bys you can do in a single query
so just for the sake of comparison we
limited to order 2 and it was still
slower yeah we also compared against
frequent items that minors so in this
case we just ran support as our
difference metric and we benchmarked
against the SP MF data mining library
both the a priori and the FP growth
implementations Almond once again we
were faster across all five data sets
yeah we also did some experiments where
we try to generalize to other engines
right so this RS explained is the ROI
and Suchi work that I talked about
earlier from Sigma 2014 and then we also
compared against a to x-ray and here we
were rated pretty much comparable
because it turns out that for data x-ray
we one thing they didn't mention is that
there's another constraint this
minimality constraint about how we
return explanations and in the case of
data x-ray they don't actually prefer
minimality they have a different
criteria called set coverage and so
there's a set coverage algorithm that
you have to run in the case of the
directory that actually ends up
dominating the runtime so you know in
this case you're just we're pretty much
even but there's no slowdown effectively
it's a two percent performance hit
moving back to the logical optimizations
that we talked about so in this
experiment we did is we essentially had
a synthetic data set and we tuned the
number of candidate foreign keys in the
tables that were generated in these
synthetic cases and so what we were
trying to find is you know is there a
clear crossover point where our adaptive
algorithm fails right so assuming that
we don't have a threshold tuning you
know can we see when our approach is
faster than naive or slower than naive
turns out that yeah it makes a lot of
sense that around 5,000 candidate
foreign keys is when our that logarithm
doesn't work but when we're actually
pruning the candidate foreign keys and
then semi joining the diff joint
optimization where we do the predicate
push down is actually quite effective
and then we also applied this to the MS
telemetry B dataset and we got a 2x
improvement in the run time for SPARC we
have basically you know two different
data sets that are bigger versions of
the previous signal data sets that I
talked about and we benchmarked this on
the latest version of spark in a cluster
from Google Cloud and we benchmarked
against the SPARC ml Lib library um so
here we ran a scalability experiment
where we tried to see you know how well
does it scale up as we increase the
number of servers and we're pretty close
to ideal this is on the census data set
and we increase the number surface 225
and throughout we're getting close to
linear scale up and we also have
benchmarks in the paper where we
compared against SPARC FP growth and
spark a priori and we also do a factor
analysis to show you the importance of
each optimization from both the single
node and a distributed case yeah and
finally we had one more extreme that I
thought was actually put interesting we
ran our version of macro by sequel and
spark at Facebook on a production
cluster using one of their production
data sets and this data set you know
it's a day's worth of data it's it's
very very large and we were able to sort
of you know answer these questions
answer these queries rather in you know
you know about 15 to 20 minutes which is
pretty pretty good because the
alternative at Facebook was using a very
very slow essentially I think it was
presto that they were using that would
just take you know hours and hours and
hours to run so we're able to accelerate
that quite a bit using macro basis equal
to recap we introduced this differ that
captures the core semantics of several
recent works and explanation finding an
explanation
engines and ideally we have this nice
singular interface now that can
interoperate with traditional OLAP
sequel we also show how we've
generalized to these industrial academic
use cases and we can hopefully capture
new use cases in the future using diff
and I think what's most exciting is that
you know with these new types of queries
that are being run and these new
interfaces hopefully that we're
proposing does this present even more
opportunities for adaptive query
optimization right what other types of
operators can we Co design with DIF for
example and we show that we can
implement DIF in an efficient manner but
there's still you know challenges I
think in terms of scalability because
you know in the case of one of our data
sets that had hundreds of columns it was
still very expensive to explore all of
these possible feature combinations so I
think there's a lot of work to be done
in implementing faster and more
efficient versions of that as well
especially I think it's not of
approximation approximate query
processing there's a lot of interesting
things that we can do I again want to
thank our collaborators one last time
from Facebook Google and Microsoft I
also encourage you guys to check out the
the macros website if you want to learn
more but at this time happy to take
questions
[Applause]
you